I want to talk about double standards
hypocrisy ignorance and general
depravity and no I'm not talking about
the Collins segment during Sean
Hannity's radio show today
I'm talking about that infamous Trump
Tower meeting there are sort of two
conflicting arguments from Donald Trump
not surprisingly about the Trump Tower
meeting that happened with this Russian
lawyer
Natalia vessel Metz kaya with the
purpose of getting dirt on Hillary
Clinton to help Trump win the election
meeting one the first one is the meeting
was totally legal
collusion isn't a crime the other is
it's actually Hillary who colluded with
Russia and she should be investigated
which of course you would only do if it
was a possible crime that was committed
yesterday on the show we focused on the
second one right the countless claims
from Donald Trump that Hillary colluded
with Russia and should be investigated
by robert muller or the FBI or law
enforcement or whoever's willing to do
it today I want to focus more on the
other part of the argument which is that
the meeting at Trump Tower with Russians
promising dirt on Hillary Clinton was
legal as Donald Trump has claimed and
this goes back to Donald Trump's tweet
over the weekend where Donald Trump
admitted for the first time that the
point of the Trump Tower meeting with
Russians was not to talk about adoptions
but to get dirt on Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump said in this tweet quote
fake news reporting a complete
fabrication that I am concerned about
the meeting my wonderful son Donald had
in Trump Tower this was a meeting to get
information on an opponent totally legal
and done all the time in politics and it
went nowhere I did not know about it
there is an excellent article in the I
believe it's the LA Times written by
former US attorney and current law
professor Harry Lippmann along with
David Lieberman were they explain the
meeting was not totally legal meeting
with a foreign power to get help with an
American presidential election isn't
legal and this is one of the most
precise explanations of the possible
criminality I've read so far and I
encourage you to read it as well there's
a federal law 18 US Code subsection 371
called conspiracy to come
an offense against or to defraud the
United States some of those Russians
indicted by robert muller already were
charged under this specific law and the
defrauding of the united states can
include quote any conspiracy for the
purpose of impairing obstructing or
defeating the lawful function of any
department of government even if the
object of the conspiracy is not a
criminal offense let's see if we can
unpack that a little bit the object of
becoming president doesn't need to be a
criminal offense I mean it isn't right
trying to be president is not illegal
but conspiracy to obstruct the way that
the Federal Election Commission says
elections are supposed to run for
example not allowing foreign nationals
to contribute to elections including
both money and things of value like dirt
on Hillary that's still a crime even if
your end goal becoming president is not
illegal in and of itself and there's
another really important part of
conspiracy law not only is the objective
not relevant the success of the
conspiracy doesn't matter
Trump even in that tweet I put up for
you insists he never got the dirt on
Hillary from Russia according to the law
as Lippmann and Lieberman explained as
long as you agreed to pursue the dirt on
Hillary from Russia conspiracy has been
committed and Lippmann and Lieberman
argue that the Trump Tower meeting fits
the description of conspiring to defraud
the United States regardless of whether
they got the dirt or didn't this ads by
the way to the speculation that Don jr.
is in legal trouble trouble elimin and
Lieberman right that molar just based on
what's publicly known could likely
already indict Donald Trump jr. so he
should be very worried even though Trump
is saying he's not at all worried
because it was totally legal and they
didn't get the dirt anyway actual law
professors say no Donald Trump jr.
should be worried and that's what we've
been thinking for the last two or three
months yeah I mean but it's gonna come
down to prosecutorial discretion right
and whether or not Muller wants to press
charges against Don Jr for this because
I mean you know we'd kind of joke about
this whole they had never worked on a
campaign
thing but that is true to some degree
like maybe he didn't know that that was
criminal and I don't look that's engage
us we don't want to press charges on him
because of this you're referring to sort
of like the intent element that is there
when it comes to crimes in the way that
this law appears to be written
regardless of whether you know that it's
against the law to do this regardless of
whether what you want help to do isn't
illegal which in this case it's not
becoming president that it would still
be a crime for which one could be
indicted but you are right I mean
regardless ultimately there's going to
be significant gray area here for
prosecutors to figure out who do they
want to charge and with what and as you
know this is just about what the public
knows I'm sure there's a lot more than
just the Trump Tower meetings so we'll
have to see not only that our entire
discussion today has been just about
conspiracy to defraud we haven't even
touched on possible obstruction of
justice witness tampering and other
crimes and hopefully Muller is looking
looking into those but again merely on
the public knowledge about the Trump
Tower meeting we have legal experts
increasingly agreeing that a try a crime
likely has been committed here we'll see
if Trump's lawyers can clean it up for
them